Hey, Vsauce. Michael here.
Music.
Why does music make us feel the way it does?
Why does music make us wanna move?
And why do songs sometimes gets stuck in our heads?
James May, from the YouTube channel Head Squeeze,
thanks for the music. Pleasure.
Why can music bring back memories?
That is a very good question actually.
I've often wondered why it has this power
actually to unlock a completely dormant
memory, something that's gone as far as you
know
and then it chooses, usually a pop tune
from say ten or twenty years ago,
bang, there you are, wherever you were at the time.
Sometimes it's positive,
sometimes it's negative,
but what is nostalgia?
Well, it turns out that nostalgia and
feeling emotions because of music and dancing
and getting songs stuck in your head
all orbit around a common theme.
Your identity.
Because, really, physically speaking,
who are you? Every single day
you are losing atoms and gaining new ones
from what you eat and drink.
It takes about five years to replace
every atom in your body,
which means that the matter that we call you today
was not part of you five years ago.
If we speed the process up we start to see
that your physical body,
really all of us, every human on earth,
is just a temporary group of atoms and
molecules that, nonetheless,
keep the same name the whole time.
Now this is what we think of when we think
of our bodies,
but to an alien, who could track individual atoms,
and only saw maybe a few frames per decade,
you would appear to be what you really
are.
A bunch of incoming atoms,
making your shape and then leaving.
So, what's consistent here?
What are you?
Nostalgia, fondly remembering the past, what you
used to do and who used to be might
simply be a way for your brain
to answer that question or at least cool
down the anxieties it causes.
Because even at a macroscopic scale,
you are always changing.
You have different friends,
different behaviors, different moods, different
tastes
all the time.
If you grew up
in the 80s, and by that I mean 1680s,
it would have been possible to have been
nostalgic for a time
before the word nostalgia existed.
That's because in 1688 Johannes Hofer coined the term
by combining the Greek words for returning home
and pain. Nostalgia was originally seen
as a quite serious medical condition,
affecting soldiers who missed home so much
that they broke down and were unable to
fulfil their duties.
The only cure, as Hofer saw it, was to
be sent home, to your home,
because nostalgia is really all about you.
Your memories, your past, who you used to be
and consequently who you are now, which
makes nostalgia an often healthy way to
answer the question
'who am I?' Well, you're a person who
remembers specific events in the past.
You existed in the past and are a continuous
being. A popular theory argues that the
psychological effects of nostalgia,
connecting with your younger self and
building a continuous
identity, are advantageous,
and so we're naturally selected to be
rewarding experiences.
You change
your habits, your friends, your job,
you learn things and forget things,
but nostalgia allows you to connect all of those
events, which is especially helpful
during times of major life
transitions, like
entering adulthood or aging,
when study showed that nostalgia
is at its strongest. But if tucking in
and lining up all of your life experiences into
a continuous story
is so advantageous, why don't we feel nostalgic for
everything in the past?
Why don't you feel nostalgia for
what happened one minute ago?
Why don't you feel nostalgic for the way this
video began?
Well, the lifespan retrieval curve
might offer some clues. It's an average plot of distinct autobiographical memories
and it reveals what is called the reminiscence
bump. A time between 15 and 30 years of
the age, where more memories are encoded.
This time in your life, both while you
are living it and later,
is thought to be important because it's
so linked to the formation of our
self-identities.
Memories formed during that bump
tend to be the ones we are most nostalgic for
and because we want our continuous
identities to be positive,
we tend to be nostalgic for good memories,
not bad ones.
Individually and collectively we also tend to be
nostalgic and reminisce
on things as if they were better than at the time they
really were.
Twenty years after leaving his hometown
Abraham Lincoln returned to it and
looking upon it remembering it
nostalgically,
he wrote these lines of poetry.
"My childhood's home
I see again and saddened with the view
and still as memory crowds my brain,
there's pleasure
in it too."
Abraham Lincoln might seem like
a quite ancient person,
someone from way back in history.
But here's some perspective.
On February 9,
1956, a date within the lives of some of
our parents and many of our grandparents,
this old man appeared on the television show
"I've got a secret."
What made him so special?
Well, he was Samuel J. Seymour,
an eyewitness.
Goodnight, Mr. Seymour.
How old are you by the way, Sir?
Ninety six.
Ninety six years old.
He was allive and in attendance at
Ford's Theatre
on the very day Abraham Lincoln was assassinated.
And he was alive recently enough to have
appeared on national
television.
Music doesn't have to bring up old memories or
make you feel nostalgia in order to help
you build an identity.
Lawrence Parsons in a great interview
discusses the fact that babies
from about six months to one-year
clearly respond to all kinds of
different
rhythms and chords when only a single note or beat
is out of place.
But after one year
babies tend to only respond to rhythms and chords
from their own culture, from the world around them.
This makes sense when you consider just
how important it is for our brains to
not only construct a continuous
individual identity, but a continuous
identity within the groups
that we belong.
We don't always get along with or
understand other people, but when two
people listen to and respond to
music, their feelings and emotions can
become more similar than if they were to
merely sit
in silence or use words with no rhythm.
So, although we are still not exactly
sure why music makes us wanna move,
the desire you have, the impulse you
have to tap your foot or
bob your head or, if confident enough, dance
when you hear a rhythm might have less
to do with the behavior you have learned
and more to do with your internal desire
to fit it. And as a consequence of our
impressive ability to communicate and be
social
it even happens when you are alone or
when you want to
dance as if no one is watching.
Speaking of dance,
William Michael Brown motion captured
good and bad dancers so he could render
them into digital stick figures
and remove all clues as to their fitness
or looks or health.
Now, figures with symmetric movement,
what we might call
good dancing, were consistently rated
as more attractive
and more desirable as mates.
But this may have less to do with music
being some special human behavior
and more to do with communication in general.
Sharing a musical experience with
someone else might just be an extreme
form
of the communication skills that were
naturally selected into us,
so that we could understand each other,
understand a motion from tone of voice
and listen.
Sweet, fatty foods
taste good because they signal our brain
that they are full of energy.
Energy that we need to survive.
This is why
cheesecake tastes so incredible.
But it doesn't mean that
cheesecake is necessary for survival.
Music might be the same way.
A happy accident of
the communication skills we developed
but fundamentally
an unnecessary one or, as cognitive
scientist Steven Pinker famously called it,
acoustic cheesecake.
If not properly chewed
a bite of cheesecake can get lodged in your throat.
But a short repetitive song can get lodged
in your brain.
It's called an ear worm.
At best it means that the song is catchy.
At worst
it means replaying over and
over and over again the same song in
your head
until you are annoyed.
According to research by James Kellaris,
nearly all of us experience ear worms.
Men and women experience them equally as
often but for reasons we don't quite
understand yet
ear worms tend to last longer for and be more irritating
to women.
Repetitive rhythms make a song
easier to reproduce in our heads and
unusual time signatures
or unresolved or incomplete musical ideas.
bother us. Perhaps because we strive to
communicate completely and clearly
so we fixate on these little snippets of
songs, replaying them over and over again
in our heads, hoping to resolve them,
which, of course, they don't, meaning that
they are quite literally a
cognitive itch.
An itch that that just gets worse
by being scratched.
Our inability to suppress
a simple thought, like the famous
"quick, whatever you do,
don't think of a pink elephant" or
the game or a song stuck in your head
might be explained by ironic process theory.
The idea that in our brains there are
two different processes going on.
One, which consciously controls what we think about
and the other unconsciously monitoring
what we are thinking about.
They share an equal amount of cognitive effort and
they're always in balance and so more
effort put into monitoring
what you're thinking about means that
there's less left to actually control
what you think about.
Spending that cognitive effort on some
other task that uses working memory like
Sudoku or
anagrams can often help get
an ear worm out of your head.
You can always just replace the ear worm
with another one, using a service like
Unhear it[.com].
Ear worms are annoying,
but music has the power to conjure up
all kinds of other emotions
when we hear it. A major reason for this
is the fact that, like our sense of smell,
music is initially processed in the same
regions of the brain that process
memories and emotion, like the amygdala.
So, maybe those are
answers - memories. You might not have the same friends and job and house and
atoms throughout your life,
but you do have the same memories,
so are you just your memories?
Well, unfortunately, that idea is a little
troublesome, because
memory loss doesn't necessarily make you
a brand new different person
and there's also the slight problem of false
memories.
These studies always freak me out.
Researchers bring in participants and
show them photographs from their
childhood
and ask him to tell a story about what
happened in the photo,
except one of the photos has been photoshopped.
It didn't really happen.
But instead of noticing
this fake image, people tend to just
make up a story and remember it as if it
really happened.
Couple weeks ago I went with Jake Chudnow,
who does the music here on Vsauce
to the Royal Observatory
in Greenwich.
We saw the seventh-largest telescope
on earth and while there, this song
was playing.
It's called "Longplayer."
Composed by Jem Finer, Longplayer is
constructed by combining different
recordings of singing bells.
They're combined in different ways,
so as to never repeat
for 1,000 years.
Longplayer began in 1999 and it will not finish,
the song will not be over for 1,000 years.
Literally, billions of humans will be born
and die before Longplayer is
finished playing.
The sound waves,
the compression waves that send Longplayer into your
ear aren't that much unlike you,
your waves of atoms, temporarily
organizing atoms or molecules but not
really causing any one atom or molecule
to stay along with you
for the entire journey.
Just as the ocean
waves and bells ring, as Alan Watts said, the
earth peoples. In a way, you are a slow
compression wave moving through
Earth's matter.
But what is your waves sound like?
Does it make people wanna dance?
It probably won't
echo around for centuries after you're
gone, but maybe, while you are here, you
can get
stuck in the head of some other
temporary wave. An ear worm that they
like and don't want to get rid of.
That'd be a nice type of wave to be.
But can music make you smarter
and can I play an instrument?
Well,
to find out, follow James and I
over to the YouTube channel Headsqueeze,
where we take a look at those
questions. And as always,
thanks for watching.
Thank you.
Seriously, follows us over.
No, seriously. Right now.
There's also a link I'll put in the description,
so it's like a piece of cake guys. Come
on.
Well, we'll be over there waiting.
He's over there, I'm over there, I'm with him
here and he's with me over there.
We won.